what's up everyone welcome to program
your moan
today we're going to be looking at a gm
smart key programming procedure
we're going to be doing it on a 2015 gmc
yukon here
but it will be the same on several
different years it's also going to be
the exact same on the
tahoe and the suburban so for this
procedure is going to uh
it's going to be to add a key you're
going to need at least one working key
already
so as you can see here we have our
working key
which is very worn and then we have our
new unprogrammed key
that doesn't work yet so we're going to
put that
unprogrammed key away for just a second
and
on our on our already working key we're
going to take the emergency key out of
the bottom
hang on to that for just a second we're
going to take the working remote
that we just took the key out of and put
it in the cup holder
so we'll just put it in there and leave
it
now we're going to take the key that we
just took out of it put it in the
driver's door
and we're going to turn it to the left
or counterclockwise
five times one two
three four five
now if we look in here
we're gonna see it says ready for remote
too
so we're gonna take our unprogrammed
remote
and we're gonna put it in the
transmitter pocket and that's located in
the center console
right here so once you have that in
there like that
you want to come over here and push the
stop start button one time
okay and then we're going to
remove the remote from the transmitter
pocket and press either the lock or
unlock button
at this point if you have any additional
remotes you'll repeat that previous step
for each remote
putting in the transmitter pocket
pressing the stop start button
and then when you remove it press either
the lock or unlock button
you can have up to eight remotes
programmed to the vehicle at one
once you're done adding remotes we'll
press and hold down the stop start
button for 12 seconds to exit
programming mode
one two three
four 5 6
7 8 9
10 11 12.
okay now this remote should work
the remote part works let me get the um
the old remote out of the car
just for a test could you take that
please just want to get that out of
there to make sure that this remote will
start the car on its own
and it does that's a working remote if
you have any questions please let me
know